bist du bereit an die arbeit zu gehen
ich bin sowas von bereit
es ist der moment in dem kamener harris
begreift was auf sie zukommt ich bin
bereit an die arbeit zu gehen gemeinsam
mit dir für dich ich bin tief geehrt und
sehr aufgeregt als joe biden harris als
vize präsidentschaftskandidatin benennt
ist sie politisch keine unbekannte lange
zeit war sie generalstaatsanwältin von
kalifornien seit 2017 ist die us
senatoren in washington
großartige nachrichten lange überfällig
dass wir eine schwarze frau aus einer
minderheit als vize-präsidentin bekommen
ich denke es ist riskant weil sie eine
sehr kontroverse kandidatin ist selbst
bei den vorwahlen der demokraten konnte
sie keine hohe zustimmung erlangen
meiner meinung nach ist sie eine
riskante wahl
ich denke wir brauchen mehr diversität
vor allen dingen im weißen haus
damit wir dort mehr leute haben zu denen
wir aufschauen können mit denen wir uns
identifizieren könnte über rasse
geschlecht beiden und harris sind eine
gute kombination für amerika beiden
bietet mit harrys dem wähler innen so
etwas wie eine alternative als alter
weißer mann wählt er eine kandidatin die
für diversität steht harris wäre die
erste weibliche vize präsidentin der usa
ich habe kamera gebeten immer die letzte
ratgeberin im raum zu sein mir immer die
wahrheit zu sagen meine schlüsse zu
hinterfragen und harte fragen zu stellen
denn sofern wir die besten
entscheidungen für das amerikanische
volk dass die beiden nicht immer einer
meinung waren auch daran erinnert sich
das land harris war ursprünglich selbst
als präsidentschaftskandidatin der
demokraten angetreten und hatte biden in
einer debatte ordentlich eingeheizt
die beiden stritten erbittert über den
schutz von minderheiten in dem punkt
behielt harris resolut die oberhand
[Applaus]
jetzt aber volle kraft gegen trump so
die botschaft auf dem
nominierungsparteitag beiden und harris
zeigen sich mit ihren ihr partner innen
und harris betont in ihrer rede auch
ihre erfahrung aus der arbeit in
strafverfolgungsbehörden
ich habe für kinder und überlebende
sexueller übergriffe gekämpft gegen
transnationale kriminelle vereinigungen
ich habe mich mit grossbanken angelegt
und geholfen eines der größten
gewinnorientierten college es das
handwerk zu legen
ich erkenne anfallen wenn ich ihn sehe
staatsanwältin später
generalstaatsanwältin für kalifornien
harris gilt als durchsetzungsstark
die verurteilung raten stiegen während
ihrer amtszeiten
gleichzeitig trat sie immer für
freiheits- und minderheitenrechte 1
diese hochzeiten sind gesetzmäßig und
rechtsgültig und es wird sie weitergeben
es ist an der zeit harris wird 1964 in
kalifornien geboren ihre indische mutter
und der jamaikanische vater kommen als
junger student innen an die universität
berkeley harris lebt nach der scheidung
ihrer eltern mit ihrer jüngeren
schwester bei der mutter an der
krebsspezialist in ihre jugend verbringt
sie in kanada weil die mutter dort
forscht kam einer harris steht für
einerseits für die vielfalt der
amerikanischen bevölkerung also eben
anders als beiden ist sie nicht weiß
sondern hat einen diversen hintergrund
das ist für die demokratische wähler
basis sehr wichtig weil die sehr viel
heterogener ist als die der republikaner
in dem sinne steht sie dann auch für die
zukunft denn die demokratische
langfristige demokratische
wahlkampfstrategie oder wahlstrategie
sieges strategie wie man so will ist es
auf den demografischen wandel der usa zu
setzen
es ist joe biden der kamera harris im
januar 2017 als us senatoren vereidigt
sie betritt die nationale bühne als
donald trump als präsident sich
anschickt das land zu verändern und
harris hält von anfang an dagegen reiht
sich ein in die reihe von
hunderttausenden frauen die beim women's
match gegen die politik des neuen
demonstrieren
ich glaube wir sind an einem wendepunkt
in der geschichte unseres landes
ich glaube das ist ein zeitpunkt der ein
ganz entscheidender moment in der
geschichte unseres landes ist als die
tram regierung die einwanderungspolitik
massiv verschärft ist harris eine der
senatorinnen die für die rechte der
sogenannten dream kinder von illegalen
einwanderer innen kämpft das ist ein
zeitpunkt der von uns verlangt dass wir
kämpfen und damit klar ist wofür das ist
ein kampf bei dem es um die liebe zum
land geht es geht um uns die wir glauben
dass wir besser sind als dass wir wissen
dass wir besser sind und wir werden
kämpfen für die gute seite in uns
kämpferisch entschlossen so agiert sie
auch im senat
das bekommt auch justizminister sessions
zu spüren
seien sie ehrlich was macht mich nervös
wenn ich so getrieben werden
als die menschen im ganzen land gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt auf die
straße gehen
mitten während der korona krise mitten
im wahljahr positioniert sich harris
deutlich wirft präsident trump versagen
vor und fordert eine weitreichende
reform der polizei wir haben darüber im
privaten aber auch öffentlich gesprochen
jetzt dass das zeit zu handeln
das volk verlangt dass und sie haben das
recht zu wissen dass ihre regierung eine
repräsentative regierung ein
repräsentant des volkes auf ihre
bedürfnisse reagiert für und salzland um
unseren idealen gerecht zu werden
eintreten für gerechtigkeit das war
immer ihr hauptmotiv auch bei ihrer
eigenen präsidentschaftskampagne camilla
harris sucht das gespräch geht auf
menschen zu
jetzt im team mit joe biden ein weg der
sie im november ins weiße haus bringen
soll